alo alo alo hóa ra cho mik à Mẹ chưa
Chào các bạn ạ
anh cũng cũng khá lâu rồi mình không gặp
nhau từ
chú tiểu sử năm tuần trước
tôi đang ngồi mà lại phổ ong một tí vì
thôi thất hẹn với ông hơi lâu à Tôi đang
ngồi mò có vẻ có vẻ nó đang ra được cái
gì đó rồi đợi tí
nhạc ừ
phụ trách
khi đăng nhập thủ công
theo là xong
có thêm điều kiện
có những điều kiện kiểm tra thêm cái
active
ừ ừ
truyền thêm cái hàm số này khi mà đăng
nhập Âu anh cũng là một cái hay để mình
để mình xử lý cái Rốt cuộc phải kiếm ít
the way nó tác dụng gì nhỉ Thế bây giờ
Qwerty thì tôi thấy nó ta không có ý
nghĩa gì lắm à
nha cuối rồi sẽ chia sẻ Nhớ nhắc nhở
mình nhé ờ
có xạo không ạ Ừ
I see a đi xem nào
a passport
you set này log in attendance
Ừ rồi Nhu rơ le stockin
thông
tin hỏi
không lưu lại
em à Có một lớp em ở đây thôi nó cho em
là được
Ừ rồi
Ừ ừ không có
dịch vụ phát gặp
a
medium Media mì tre phải mở mạng
khi cài từ sau
Em hãy mở vp.en
ờ ờ multiball xe top model defy grab như
thế này
ô kê hát như này mình sẽ có vài grab đời
và cặp Movado ở đây
ở quê cái này một mình một Rider thôi
không cần gì à Chắc là mình được bôi đây
là u xơ không Trước tôi làm nhầm Thằng
em mình có nhiều người ghen nhưng mà
chúng chúng một bộ Rider sẽ áp ở đây
Ừ rồi xấu ăn Min box in format date last
attempt Rup and unite Ok
ạ sau đó thì me the way là gì nhỉ
anh đi tơ
khi quét Amino Acid amin Blade
I
miss the weather like
a ghost
ừ ừ
remix If our cái gì đó
of có phải này
[âm nhạc]
wi-fi luôn Ngon mình sẽ chỉ cần dùng
file Thôi mất công tạm cái file
middleware ăn midwest check làm gì cả
tốt nhắc thì nó
ở đây có cái ghé sợ đây có sử dụng cái
này
bây giờ mình à
khi sử dụng
Ừ mình cũng sẽ sử dụng đến nay out
ô ô ray ozzie cơ
Ở đây có gì cả vào đây là war ii
ừ ừ
bộ gd&đt
à à
Chúng tôi sẽ sửa lại cái file này một tí
file này là lấy từng góc rồi chất Thôi
thì
ừ ừ
của từng thằng à
Ừ nếu mà thành công thì về hôm tuần
thằng đúng nhỉ à
a row service khi bé hôm từng thẳng ở
đây mặc định là hôm
Em thử mới biết được ngoại
em
dấu dấu này á Giàu này là là có thể
truyền hơn mọi được
để mọi thêm thêm rất nhiều tham số và
những cái tham số lấy khi chuyển vào nó
sẽ biến thành ma nó sẽ truyền thêm vào
theo dạng mà và nó sẽ có ghi chính là
khi kia tức là vì ví dụ nha ví dụ nhé là
sửa Tôi có một cái phong trần kiểu ngay
tăng Trần cộng cộng hai số thì bình
thường là mình sẽ truyền A và B ngay
đúng không ạ sau đó thì Duy Tân trở về
kết quả cậu b rồi đúng không Nhưng mà
ông sẽ thấy là thế Giả sử Tôi muốn
truyền cái Hàn là truyền thật 10 số cũng
được năm chục số được là nó sẽ in ra kết
quả của tất cả thì sẽ như nào thì đấy nó
sẽ khái niệm là bây giờ mình sẽ viết sửa
lại đây nó sẽ là kiểu 300 nha để biến nó
thành mà sau đây sẽ không một Android
như thế này sau đó thì ông sẽ vịt tôn
chị ạ xăm kiểu kết quả của toàn bộ với ế
đi bộ ở đây đấy Còn nếu không thì ông sẽ
phải ghi cụ thể ige không + Ly một Giả
sử là sử là ông truyền vào đây theo kiểu
là số tự nhiên này còn nếu mông truyền
theo kiểu egreat Yêu cầu là ở abc nó sẽ
kiểu khác
tôi nhớ Thế thôi nhớ Thế cũng nhớ hình
như nó biến định hàng không 11 thì phải
cái đấy Tôi không chắc lắm là tao ít
dùng này thôi dùng kiểu tại một cái
chuyện loa như thế này
Anh thường là tôi truyền vào là dạng mà
tới Tạo Hàn mà nó chuyển hàng bà
à à
đợi tí tôi sửa lại đoạn này phát grab
đây là có cái góp là thì truyền Bà
chuyên vào không thì nách à
Ở nhà đang hơi bị ngứa
Ừ nếu mà thành công à điều hướng Nếu mà
đã lắp pin à
ừ ừ
ừ ừ tôi vẫn phải tạm cám in ra đi rồi
tôi sẽ bắt chước theo thằng này
à à
em tự nhiên và rồi bị xóa mất cái Linh
plus ở để xem nhé Ở
ý nghĩa là có khi không khác gì thì sao
có gì sai sai Đây Rồi
I always
Ừ
bắt trước đây tạo à
I am in
à à
quanh việc là làm à à
anh em biết được nghe không phải là hàng
ngày
xã Hà Hồi trước copy được nghỉ
Anh Quân
tháng mới đi
à à
ừ ừ
ở đây mình sẽ là
I grabbed ở đây là ăn bim
thành công thì sẽ cho Tôn
Ừ
để xem nha
ý nghĩa mà không thành công thì v lít
điều hướng quay về
Ê mày về Cái Trang thì gì đó mình sẽ tơn
về trang đăng nhập không ạ
trang đăng nhập là
về bản chất là mình sẽ Ariston về router
à à
Naruto tiền log in ngoặc
gọn biết the way nhé sau đó thì bên Roto
service này mình sẽ là amin này
bèo tôi cứ vừa đăng nhập cho mấy ông xem
lại lôgic nhá Tôi đang làm lại cái vụ
đăng nhập hội trước tự nhưng bị lỗi tự
nhiên là mình loạn hết cả lên vụ ao ấy ý
ờ
ờ tôi đăng nhập lại này
thì mình sẽ vào cái Hàn đăng nhập này
đúng không ạ và đăng nhập này sau đó thì
mình ghi vào trong class này cái các
amin mình đăng nhập với tư cách của user
này
đúng nhà mình sẽ tôi sẽ thụ D thử đầu
tiên là rau này tiếp theo là ở
à à
a b đi out
à Xong rồi trò đến
a
wash là amin số ngồi chó đến trách như
này cho bến xem nhé Ở đây đây giờ
khi mà tôi nó tin thử vào này
à à
Maria ở chỗ ông dạy ờ ờ
nếu mà nếu mà tôi đúng thì ở trang này
là bạn trang 99 Nguyễn Minh tranh đúng
không Nếu đúng bạn đấy thì bạn ở sinh
viên của tôi xin cũ
hi vọng in check
Đúng rồi
Khi mà mới đăng khi 10 mới đăng ký thì
mặc định mình sẽ lạ áp này cần chứ không
phải là mình là amin họa nên nó đang bị
về lên trường hợp này xảy ra là sử thổ
cư Giả sử nha tôi có cho mặc định bạn
đợi la mini
thứ hai là sử có trong mặc định bạn đấy
là ăn Minh ạ Tuy nhiên là đây là đang
test nhé ăn Tết nhé á
à à
rồi bạn để hết tôi chẳng cần dậy thì bạn
ấy cũng sẽ tự tự sẵn thôi những người
giỏi thì ra chẳng cần dạy mình chỉ cần
định hướng đúng người ta thôi
còn truyền cảm hứng được người ta hỏi
con đã có sẵn tư duy rồi mà đúng không
ở đấy có vẻ check xem thử mày có về
thành công này Ok Thế coi như mấy ông
thấy đúng không Nếu không có thấy những
là tôi đang đăng nhập zô amin và cái gót
này được rồi Thành công rồi đúng không
Bây giờ tôi
a cho tôi muốn vào là sử Tôi muốn vào
cài router là amin post như thế này thì
bản chất là nó sẽ đi qua cái gì sẽ đi
qua những cái tham quý phi cả amin nó sẽ
đi qua cái middleware là juanmi này cái
áo amin này bản chất là mình đã khai báo
bên này là đi qua thằng này một là ông
khai báo bên này hay là ông khai bảo
phải bảo thẳng luôn đấy cũng được khai
báo thảm me the weather luôn đây như này
cũng được đấy tôi khi khai báo hàng ở
đây đi cho nó đỡ chồng có vẻ đó khó hiểu
là như thế này
nó thì sẽ hiểu là sẽ thông qua thằng ăn
mi này khá mi này bản chất là nó sẽ lại
kiểm tra trách của mình thôi à
ừ ừ
nhỉ Ừ nhưng mà mình cứ thử làm chai hàng
trở lại nhé Nó sẽ D ở đây một này và đây
ở đây hay đi
xem Thực sự nó sẽ nhảy và thằng nào
vụ tai nạn
đó nó vẫn ngồi thành một tôi cũng thấy
lạ Tại sao phải out này nó không nhận
được cái này nhá Tôi rõ ràng là vừa nãy
mình vừa check
Ừ Mình sang bên Roto này có thể vẫn
không được
Nghe ca nhạc
khi sex
em vẫn làm à Mình gót mình mình log in
vào rồi hai remember của nó bị mất à
way này sẽ không ở đây đúng không ạ sau
đó thì mình sẽ vào một cái file file xin
file Mình đang ở mình Đang chuẩn bị vào
làm inbox này đúng không là gì đấy Kể
đúng không Mình sẽ thử DD out
ở
cách này trong trường hợp của gót này
Watch
bộ sách này à
ở đây là phone hết
à OK OK để chứng tỏ là không nên quan Mỹ
điệu quê mình mà đăng nhập xong đăng
nhập về bên này xong lọc in này xong nó
không remember cho tôi
có ai đây đây đây
đây chua
i
m ở thủ tục
Em thử lại nha Có bay để tôi hình chung
rồi
em nhập lại này
truyền lắm rồi nhỉ
cái một cột remember Token
Ừ Ok Ok Thế giờ mình sẽ thêm một cột nữa
là cột ab tóc em
5.8 vẫn dùng bây giờ vẫn dùng đúng không
Thế là không ăn trọng về việc phiên bản
cũ phiên bản mới tự nhiên là nó sẽ ngoài
việc là nó Cốt nó khó hơn ít pop ít hỗ
trợ hơn nó có một tí liên quan đến bảo
mật một tí thôi và liên quan đến tốc độ
xử lý khá nhiều
5.8 thì tôi nhớ không lầm mình như là nó
không tp70 hỗ trợ được cái bệnh ồ
này xịn nhưng mà không đưa mình sẽ phải
enter cái bàn mà U D E
khi enter
rapper Token to the table ô
thì mình sẽ thêm cột này và
chắc à sẽ được
thì tại sao phải cần cái ghim bấm tóc em
nó giống như ở cái á Mình lưu lại theo
dạng là Cookie mình lại Coffee để mà mỗi
lần mình truy cập lại vào trang web mình
sẽ gửi Cookie lên họ to Kem lên cho
người dùng để nuôi dùng để mà hiểu được
cái trình duyện cái
nói chung là để mới hiểu được là là
người dùng này có quyền đăng nhập vào
Ai
thèm
thuê bros rồi không ạ
Có luôn là Remember i
Ừ
Ok
bạn chắc ở đây Trần Trinh này để phô thì
không có after để cuối cũng được
ở thành phố nó sẽ luôn Apple đi à
khi cài súng dưới nếu là sửa ông về sau
muốn xóa rốt rồi đi là không nên xóa
mình cứ để tạm mày đã à
anh em tôi có lum Tôi muốn cho Apple nào
đây optical mà
không có before tờ nghỉ
thôi chẳng cần không chọn
chạy có thể bấm đây Dạ này
anh chị mãi
ok rồi này
a fast now She likes dệt ý ở lại nha
à à
đồng hồ có vẻ là được Có vẻ đang đăng
nhập đăng nhập được rồi là tôi sẽ thử
test thôi là bên này à Lại tra này vẫn
là phone
khi cai nhỉ
em hết hỏi khác hay không phải khá rồi
đó
à à
em gọi cho anh Hà mà
khi Nami nha à
à à
nhập được thôi
vẫn hỗ trợ mà
à à
khi tỉa Ví dụ ở thằng Facebook nó sẽ
phải có cái đường Linh có bác cụ thể
phải đăng ký của nó hoặc cái thằng
Google này vậy Còn mấy thằng khác thì nó
dạng hơn chị nó cấp quyền cho mình cái
đoạn này nó dễ à
Vì sao bạn này vẫn không được nhỉ Cái
nghỉ làm giống hệt ai đấy
Em hãy Note em à
ừ ừ
Mở Zalo
ở đây là tem đi anh
sex gai
thế 1 sửa đi trở lại mỗi người vào đăng
nhập
này ta lại này vẫn là phone
anh có nhà
à à
Ừ cái này hình như là không phải do cốt
của mình mà đau của mình đang có vấn đề
gì
à à
chứ không phải là cốt mấy ông hình dung
không Tôi nghĩ không phải cô đâu Ờ
anh em
cho xem
cái tát quất vậy
Ừ ông mặc định nó hát hộ mình mà đúng
không
Seasons and này nữa thôi nhá
anh thêm ấy chưa Chị cố cố làm cái gì ở
thôi chứ không phải là đăng nhập hội vậy
à à
lên
có ai sau khi quét Thị Mỹ
em
gọi anh season Translate rồi mà
à à
anh không được nữa thì à
mẹ mìn chua ấy ta lại này gọi không được
họ đậu xanh
Em hãy cho đi đề đây nó dừng nghỉ rồi
nhá bỏ Đời Đi Nhé
Ừ được rồi
I love
ở trên đó rồi
không có đồ đây Ngã
lời
bài hát không cần mấy ông thấy ở đây làm
gì có hát khủng gì đâu
à à
anh suốt not have in Common balo đang
forward Automatic cầu tự động hát hộ
mình rồi
lưu lại trong đây bê hộ mình anh hàng ra
là mình phải lưu lại cái mã hát đấy
chính tài liệu của thằng thằng này nó
chỉ có mỗi cái vụ rất là đơn giản là log
in
anh như này là xong
cho vợ đơn giản à
anh ơi
em
có cái gì cả chỉ có đúng như này thì đào
ra cái vụ thêm cái gì đó kia này
ở lại nha
ta lại này ấy
thì nó phải nhìn nhá Đúng không nói gì
nữa đơn giản bơ nói
cho
bọn có ghim bờ ao Vẫn không ra ngoại cảo
này luôn không ra à số 1A
showbiz này hiểu xem có khi là do cái sờ
đít này
đi xe truy cập bằng cái này tôi thứ ba
lại nha à
có bác cái hút của mình đang bị như này
sẽ đổi lại nó thành nhà ngay đi
Em bấm vào này
cái xô viết này đi vậy
ừ ừ
ở đâu nữa
à à
chỉ có bác của mỗi trong ngày yêu mình
Ô hay Nói chưa lia cái compiz rồi
Ừ
để tôi có đi anh nhá thì ra mấy ông thể
tạo phím tắt để clear một cái Coffee
kiểu đó tôi hồi trước và tôi nhớ thôi
từng tặng phải ở
hai tay AC nó sẽ Italia hết toàn bộ con
thích
ừ ừ
Ở đây có clockwerk
à à
bổ
sung 2kc nhau lỗi
ừ ừ
ở Pháp
Ừ nó như này đó thì chạy cái này
em Trả lại cho em
ở lại và sáng tác dụng điểm
anh vẫn bị cái này hình như cái này mình
khai báo ở trên ghế hát Vì vậy nữa Thế à
à à
Ừ đấy Buồn cười khai báo trên hấp phổi
vẫn là khai báo lại ở bên kia cũng chả
tác dụng gì
ừ ừ
dõi mình phải bảo tại Hà Nội anh yêu
điềm gì à
Nghe có vẻ đăng nhập đồng A nó nhập được
nha
ở bên post này
từ Vinaphone à
Ừ
chắc chắn là cái vụ web của tôi của mộ T
có thể máy thôi có thể vấn đề không biết
người ông tôi nghĩa Tôi sẽ để cốt ở đây
để cho mấy ông ạ
xe tải về thử trải nghiệm nhé
em làm thử
Phú Quốc về xong rồi phụ chạy xem được
nha nếu mà sửa được cho tôi rủ our tốt
thấy Đức Chị thấy có vấn đề quá ơi ở
à à
Ừ hai cái này kệ không có trọng nữa
chị sẽ làm bên A
là
dùng ck Alistar tố quên không nhắc thì
cái xe cái tơ nó là gì sẽ cái tơ có
level từ xem
cái cái tơ nó là gì nó cái thứ viện để
mình hoàn toàn thế kiểu Điền dạng kiểu
Block như hàng thêm rất nhiều ảnh cái
thứ thứ rất là ngôi nhà ông hình trong
sẽ hiển thị ra kiểu đăng cái blog này
hình như mất tiêu rồi nhớ mất tiền nhà
mình có bản miễn phí mình cha Ừ hình như
thằng paper như nó có hỗ trợ một cái
hiểu đăng gì vậy tiểu tử thối lại nhé
không phải ở công ty nào chơi chơi cái
tơ đâu một công ty nó hệ dùng kiểu tấm
Nhưng công ty thôi à xuống cái gọn nhẹ
hơn bởi vì bởi vì không phải sẽ cái tên
là thích hợp rất nhiều cái nhưng không
phải là chính vì tốt hộp rất nhiều cái
em đôi khi nó hơi thừa đôi khi nhiều cái
mình không cần thì ra là
đây cái tơ này
ở đấy có thể dùng cái này đấy ở trong
cái hyper 2 pro này thì nó có thích hợp
Summer nốt không phải sẽ Kaito cũng được
anh xin nghỉ đi
a
symbol đang nó có rất nhiều cái hỗ trợ
này
tất cả như này được đôi khi là mấy ông
chỉ cần mấy cái giỏ ngay thôi chẳng hạn
thế
a này viết mắc đao này
Ừ cái này là
anh vẫn chung cài xong mà nốt thì phải
ngôi hai cái có hai cái này cốt của nó
sẽ rất đơn giản như này cho em thêm đôi
Summer nốt vào là xong à
hình sẽ đứng nhiên mình sẽ chạy lên biệt
thự chèn thêm cái access này thì chuyện
em về vào được Cần cho ngu vậy
Có sao mơ xa mờ Nốt này đúng không xong
nốt ghét như mình gửi cho em trước cả
xong một nốt cho xé đã chuyển tiền bạc
hết mùi rồi public này CF này trên theo
tôi sẽ nốt vào ok
mình sẽ code như thế nào tốt Mình sẽ chỉ
cần nào gọi cái đít Xong rồi gọi gì đó
của nó là xong
ở đít rồi Gì nhỉ à
Ừ để mô xong rồi nút à để mua xong một
nút này
anh
không cần đoạn Chúng ta mở được chứ gọi
đến cái cm nốt ngay được rồi đấy có thêm
vài cái chú thích thêm thì ông lên hàng
cái á trang của 60 nốt mà xe
thì mình sẽ mình sửa lại cái đít hôm
trước nha mình cái đít
Suốt này đúng không
ừ ừ
army này boltzmann led này
Anh quay mình này không ạ Alo thử thử Gà
bây giờ mình sẽ tặng Xóa ngay đi mình sẽ
có ID là là teck zhi qua mình Nga chẳng
hạn làm gì để mà mình sẽ chen ơi cuộc
sống một nốt ở trong này
cùng đi xài quá không biết uống ở đâu
đấy chấm xong mà nốt tự nhiên với mình
chèn thêm thư viện không ạ chèn thêm hai
thư viện thư viện một cái là axit là
Ừ nó là ghép phải chèo có gì nhỉ
bộ phim sex phim sec
1 cái như thế một cái trên này
Anh thường à ông sẽ viết ở trên này nó
Linh
à à
anh khó copy nghỉ à
em sửa lại các đoạn lại tí
access này khi sex
Ừ ok
ạ Bây giờ mình muốn gọi thằng kia mình
sẽ truyện ngắn gọi chứ nản gọi được cái
hàm song với nốt được à
ta có
chú chó béo thế chị nào khi nào nó đang
bị kiểu nó nó mặc nó mặc định thì nó sẽ
chiếm luôn cả cái vùng vùng này ông có
thể chia tỉ lệ nó là 8 rồi đấy 4 cũng
được cho thằng bé lại
à à
cho nó hiểu ngay
Ừ cái này có thể tôi nghĩa nó sẽ cho
mình sẽ cho
dâu không biết chị dâu trong ngày được
không rau bằng
30 mà Mới hơi to đấy em
à à mặc định nó sẽ co lại có thể nó sẽ
tự chuyển sẽ phải có lãi Cái vụ này
cái này nó đang mềm chán cái nhá trên
này nó về hơi xấu nó bị mờ đúng không ạ
ở đoạn này chắc là mấy ông sẽ tự sửa lại
xét nhé Mấy ông cha sang một nốt đến thư
viện của nó xem sửa lại với cái á thì
con thích cấu hình của nó như là của
smile thế này đây tôi sẽ chỉ để mua ở
đây cho mấy ông xem thôi tôi không sửa
nhiều ra diện không tốn quá nhiều thời
gian để giao diện đúng không ạ Nếu hoàn
toàn thể lên đây xe Xipo và sửa lại cho
nó diện theo ý mấy ông nhá Ừ
A
và cái này cái này mặc định lưu ý mấy
ông sẽ hiểu là mặc định cái này lưu ví
dụ cho sự Cho ảnh hai thằng hạn Không ạ
là sự có ảnh đây là chẳng hạn không ạ
thì bản chất là khi mình lưu thì mình
lưu ý thì nó sẽ Mình sẽ lưu cái gì trong
này là sử về tôi có chọn hai đầy đủ nha
đừng có điên hay đủ thông tin là sửa
ngày không ạ cho tôi ingress không ạ thì
mặc định tôi sẽ lưu những cái gì tôi sẽ
vào admin cần cho lo boss lại nóng lạnh
mình thủ
a b d cái thằng ở đây mình có đi trơn
rồi thì ăn class thì ông sẽ thấy đó à
nó
báo lỗi gì à
xin lỗi gì mà nóng
chị xem nhé Nếu mà nó không đều thường
như thế lỗi có thể đổi ra showbiz này
a Zip laze có vấn đề gì đó virus
ở nhà đất có vấn đề
Vì sao này đây lại có vấn đề gì đấy
à à
mình gọi lên cái này
dùng Ajax để đẩy lên tôi tôi đang bị
nhầm sang điều hướng nhìn thấy Vấn đề
cái Play ở đây nó đang
Ừ nó bị lặp lại do là
mô hình xử lý ở dưới này
vì thế nếu mà Mị béo thấy bị dài cốt bị
ra clip dài quá ấy không lỡ hơi khó chịu
nghỉ ngon Mình ở đây mình có Violet này
chắc Company này
anh ở đây không có đến replay cái gì mày
ạ Tại sao mà Play
a Switch from
à à
thông báo ra thành công với thất bại đây
nhờ tôi tôi chữa làm đoạn notified thì
trông có vẻ hơi bị khó chịu cho người
dùng sẽ không hiểu được không ạ
Đây bản chất mình tăng nhà Ông thấy
không khi mình chuyển lên bản chất là
mình chuyển đến tên như này trở nên thể
tê rồi chuyền in bago như thế này cho
bản chất là cái ảnh này của mình sẽ là
nó sẽ kiểu biến thành bay64 Mình lưu lại
mình không lưu lại đường dẫn này mà Mình
lưu loại ảnh theo dạng và bây 64 đấy cho
mình sẽ lưu toàn bộ toàn bộ toàn bộ Đồng
Nai vào tay ngoại thì hôm trước mình bảo
là nếu mà Company tồn tại rồi thì mình
sẽ à
thì mình sẽ sắp force họ đầu tiên mình
kiểm tra Company Company tồn tại rồi thì
mình sắp microphone đây nó ạ à
Ừ ngày mai sắp xít thì mình sẽ bản chất
mình sẽ chẳng làm gì cả Mình sẽ chỉ ẩn
ẩn nó đi thôi ông ạ
Anh hiểu sao nó bắn cái lỗi gì đó đây
này
xe đẩy lên thành công
có gì đó lại không bán đi không còn đi
thế Ok rồi
tại nó phải thông báo ở đây đúng ạ Các
bạn phải làm một cái thông báo đây tôi
đang tôi đang nỡ bắt nó đi
Ừ ông sẽ phải thông báo một cái thành
công ở đây khi mà sắp sắp ít xong được
cái Ford
bên này mình sẽ xử lý như sau mình sẽ
đưa nhau không trả về thứ mình vừa đẩy
lên đúng không ạ Mình sẽ lưu lại tất cả
đồng này lưu lại trong từng Bảng 1 đóng
ngoặc ạ
thì mình sẽ lưu lại từ
ở đầu tiên đầu tiên đó là mình cứ giả sử
của bài toán là lúc đầu chưa có Company
như thế này ấn và flast này nó sẽ đi ra
phẩm như này Hôm trước mình Nam rồi đoạn
ai nhỉ Hôm trước mình Nam rồi làm này để
làm nốt đoạn này lại nhá xong rồi mình
làm tiếp nha Cái for mày mua đồ vậy Tôi
đang hơi bé này sẽ để cái mua đồ to lên
mua đồ này là mua đồ đây
Ừ ông có thể tôi nhớ không lầm mà đây
thì sẽ là mua đồ rồi thêm Lợi next như
thế này chẳng hạn nó sẽ to hơn này thử
nha à
Em kiếm cái gì đó đây không ạ ấn vào này
chứa toàn không tồn tại thì mình class
nó sẽ mua đồ vẫn bé
bố mẹ tôi sai đâu không làm này chắc bà
mua đồ
ừ ừ
khi bé được nghỉ
like content
khi con tên là
anh cũng không ảnh hưởng hết đồ
Ừ cái gì ở đây khi nó nó bé Rồi nhỉ à à
Ừ
cái gì cố định ở đây cho nó bé đâu là
anh nhỉ
anh Alex raid kiểu nhà chọn to tại tối
Đăng dung ok ok address
a R1 R2
mình sẽ điên à
xe Zip Code pole I
ừ ừ
chị ship code này à
đúng
ca nhạc Mình sẽ điền dạng number ở đây à
a phone number
a number điện không + chắc cũng được
đương nhiên là lời khuyên là mấy ông
không Nhà ông thấy rất nhiều nơi nó sẽ
cho trọn cả mã mã kiểu mã nan truy các
từ thứ cộng 84 xong rồi mới số lần sau
nhớ mình đang về các bạn đi nữa mà việc
mình có thể bỏ qua vụ đấy cho người dùng
nhập cái thứ thứ đơn giản cơ bản còn
không là mấy ông về sau ôm hàng cái phom
phom của một thằng đó về người ông thấy
phòng đẹp không thấy là được không cần
là phức tạp hơn thế Ở đây mình sẽ có
thêm là
thêm cái à
ừ ừ
Em email email
ở đây là email ba cái logo logo này bản
chất là mình sẽ
ờ ờ
Mình sẽ lưu lại ở trong thư mục anh cho
mình đưa đường dẫn không ạ thì cái à
thế nào nhỉ
a logo ảnh
Thật ra thì mình có thể chơi cái trò là
khi mà đăng ảnh xong thì mình sẽ preview
xem trước cái ảnh đấy được
vì nó có cơ chế đấy
review
image
CF trở lại
I really đi này
gì đấy
sau khi mình đăng ảnh lên
Ừ thì nó sẽ làm gì đó không
có phải đúng không mọi in to find
ạ sau khi
oneclick thì bản chất là ngày nay nó sẽ
truyền các đường dẫn vào trong thời
inmate này mà mình sẽ có hai cho nó
chẳng ạ là 100 triệu ngay đi
thật Buddy này bước nghỉ tại cha mày
Ừ cái khó chịu của cái mua đồ như thế Cứ
mỗi lần mình tải lại sang mình sẽ bị mất
cái mô đồ Đang hiển thị
à à
anh cần gì phải thư viện gì không phức
tạp đúng không chơi kiểu như này cho đẹp
Em hãy thì ok rồi đúng không Chấm chị mà
Tôi thấy trong sĩ được
bắt đầu rộn suốt ngày luôn
thế Ngon rồi đúng không chọn cái lập tức
hiển thị ra cái ảnh mà người dùng đã
chọn logo mà chỉ cần phải bé này thôi
đấy à
a son điên toàn bộ thông tin có phải cái
có mỗi cái này bắt buộc phải điện
mình sẽ là mình sẽ phải lưu lại cái tự
nhiên mình sẽ phải lưu lại cái fortnite
Ừ
mình vẫn phải dùng Ajax để mà đầy cán bộ
phải dữ liệu của sao mày lên chứ mình
không thì không
ở đoạn này mình không kiểu truyền hướng
đúng không ạ
ở
cái đoạn này chỉ copy code ở trên mạng
về mà chả có gì ghê gớm gì đấy Ở chỗ mấy
ông Tính trước Nếu nghị trước thì cái
bài toán này là một cái tốt rồi chứ còn
cốt thì rõ ràng tôi có cũng có trên mạng
về chúng ta đều có trên mạng về da như
nhau Ờ
hai iPhone semaphore mở day for này
chính xác ở đâu đấy Mình sẽ có hai cái
phone đấy do tôi để lên Ford Focus là
mình sẽ đặt tên cái form nữa form a a
à à
sau khi sửa luôn cả for press ở trên
cũng được để hiểu là Chris Porter
để phân biệt ra
[âm nhạc]
Hero in lỗi
32 Hàng ngày tôi thấy đang giống nhau
Ừ để tao sắp Milk foam để cơ bản nó khá
giống nhau đều xem nhé
nhưng mà thằng nó sẽ sắp full post và
một hàng không
để xem nào ạ
ừ ừ
cả
à à tạo tới lớp trưởng tôi đến Mỹ phát
đi mày ông trò mày tôi ngay cả
ờ ờ
cái là cả đạo check sẽ bằng thằng này
nói đến cái thằng mà quét này kiểu đi
hai nói đi
thế này
Ê bà đây sẽ post
những hình ảnh object siro nhà tại sao
tôi phải làm dạo này tôi muốn mà mình sẽ
truyền cực hay vào trong như này
bạn trong trường hợp này mình sẽ có một
cái răng sắp mi form đấy sơ mi form mà
a post
Company được Còn khi mà mua đồ này điền
điền điền các thứ thứ rồi thì mình sẽ
gọi đến hàng submit form này nhưng mà
dạng khác mình Dạ nhà
thì dạ không Con đi đâu
Chờ Đợi tí Đợi tí khi bấm vào cái nút ở
đây mình sẽ sắp ít cái phom Company đấy
Hay nó thay ở đây trong trường là bố
tuần sẽ
a wondrous Price from đây mình sẽ truyền
đây là Company ngay
Ừ rồi nhé
ghi đấy nó sẽ bị lỗi nghe nó mới sắp ít
for cả gì hết
Em thử thử lại nhé
à Anh ơi Grande nó bị nó bị điều hướng
nhanh quá về chắc chắn là lỗi cốt chỗ
nào đấy rồi tí xem Tại sao lỗi nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng nhỉ
anh nghe bạn này nó không xử lý được
anh không được được chứng tỏ tôi ghi cốt
dispatch ở trên này có thể bị lỗi gì đó
Gì đó rồi
thế này do cái đoạn mình có thêm đấy nhỉ
on click on ninfood amply
ở tạm xóa đi này à
khi sex
những ngôi sao bóng đá
khi mình đã làm cái gì đó Sai sai đây
lại còn tết hết à Ừ
ai
thèm đoạn hết vào trong này có gì Đông
sao nhỉ
a press + like
em không thấy có gì sai ở đây cả
hẳn đi xem nào
à à
thế một phát vào nhà nó sẽ ngừng nó sẽ
ngừng chạy ngay
Ừ cái kiểu nhà bị ngừng chạy ngay
Ừ tôi có sửa một chỗ ở đó có vấn đề rồi
chị xem nhé
Ừ ông méo thể mở cái à
Ừ đợi tí đã thì đợi thì thôi quyền
chương trình cái A
Ừ
ông có thể xem cái cái
clip ở đây này
anh Tràn thêm sửa cái này đổi cái này
đổi cái này Ok này Thế mai đi thằng này
ngày cũng thế mai đi ông ạ sửa sửa sửa
đây là Swift mình làm gì bí ẩn hỏi đi
Xóa dòng đây
Ừ anh hết toàn bộ thằng ngày
anh không thêm cái gì cả Vì sao đoạn ra
cướp ngày nào Xin lỗi nha à
đây đó là à đây đây đây đổi này rồi tôi
nói tôi ngay phải là Kris post xong rồi
nó như này đúng karaoke Sao nó cứ tự
động điều hướng Ok Ok chiều rồi
Tại sao này
có gj gj mới bị mà nó trường hợp tinh
thế còn mấy cái Facebook khác là nó kiểm
tra hết cho ông từ đầu đến cuối mà không
sợ bị kiểu như thế nó hiền đi format ok
ok đấy
thì mình sẽ truyền dữ liệu trong như thế
này
ạ sau đó thì ở đây ulrich rồi
ra ngay đúng
em thật sự là người ôm trọn mỗi ảnh Tôi
đang quan tâm được à đầy ảnh lên sẽ đầy
được không
Anh sẽ bán luôn luôn ở đây một cái nó
lỗi
Vì
sao đây lỗi lùn à à liên quan Office
Euro trở về nó vấn đề tôi truyền cho anh
cái gì ở đây nói chuyện lên ở đây à
ngày
à mà thằng này nó sẽ đẩy lên nó sẽ đẩy
lên cái đường dẫn là
kompany store anh biết hôm trước cũng
trước thì như mình tạo như mình chưa làm
gì với nó cả tơ này
ăn mì này
khi kompany Store
Lê Minh Quân mình còn chưa tạo cái về
mấy thớt đấy cho nick store nha trở lại
không ạ Đây mình sẽ có request a Ừ cái
này thực ra mình phải ra đất rồi vì cái
đoạn này nó liên quan việc mà là
ý cho cho cả h&r có thể tạo mà tôi có
tạm
bỏ qua lại
khi
nuôi tên về
lại bạn ơi
cái file ảnh để lên Tôi đang thấy ở đây
là tôi đang truyền đây là mấy thứ thật
top nhưng không biết đầy được cái ảnh
lên không em bây giờ mình sẽ lại Bởi vì
nếu mà chuẩn thì đẩy file ảnh lên thì nó
sẽ là barry là cái tay ạ là một cái file
em gái
anh ở đây này
à
anh còn lên hoài mà nhỉ
Đúng rồi nhờ trong phòng này của mình là
mình thiếu cái em clip Nếu nhiều không ạ
asked
chị xem phim Đoạn này từ chén thêm được
file khắp thế
Ừ Lâu lâu làm không nữa ở đây này chuyện
đêm file would find One Piece a home
depot thì hiển thị ra ok ê
bài hát nữa thôi nhớ hấp cái Isaac kẻ
Sắp rồi cũng phải sửa thêm cái đoạn nữa
đấy đấy Tôi đang thử với She writes em
Hàn đấy có lấy được không thôi
Nghe có vẻ không lấy được không ạ thì
mình mới bắt đầu này Iraq goodbye I
thế này
ở đây nó sẽ cần là mình sẽ cần à
này vào trong đấy thì nó mới lên được
truyền lên
a banditoz Australia 0g
Ừ mẹ kế đoạn đằng sau rồi tôi không biết
là ai áp Hình như đoạn phải phải chèn
thêm các bạn đấy mới chuyển được wifi ở
C like này cái hạt C Like là không nhận
diện được cái for mà for có chứa Nếu tôi
sẽ phải ghi lại thêm cái đoạn này này đó
giết ở đây Cái này cái này chỉ là đùa
giấy này
cô
gái gọi họ chết ở đây là thằng này
khi sex
anh khóc đây otic này như thế đây sẽ là
off-track
ngay Iphone data mình sẽ truyền thông
báo ta lên
À thế à
Ừ nó cực thuộc Pháp
yếu là cốt mà có gì đâu mày mình kiểu
hình dung được cách xử lý bài toán cho
mình đi cốt
không cần phải làm gì đó đủ và các siêu
ở đây cả
ừ ừ
cách lên đồ mới cái gì đó phương trình
elip
chứ không chuyển lên được
e5cc like mình sẽ thừa con solo chấm
rock cái thằng này
khi sex
cả ngày nó gọi đến thằng này
I just from some ít
d-expert
anh em phải trả thêm một cái đoạn à
lợn Đấy trên thêm được vì sao mình thì
bóp Phong cho ta này fan này
hơn
Em xài lại không cần mà
anh nghe nhạc
rồi OK OK
em phải chuyển lên được này
ừ ừ
mình sẽ thử ở lại nhá cái trả về này
không trở về được cụ thể cái file đâu
thì mình sẽ phải ở đây mình sẽ mình sẽ
gọi cụ thể file này
mã số logo à Ở nhà chẳng hạn anh
em xem nó có ra được nha
được file đấy thế Buồn rồi cái đồ đấy à
không ạ ờ
đã có trên digischool hoặc và cái kênh
ID của mình
ờ ờ
đây mình Bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ cần lưu lại
toàn bộ những cái đấy thôi đúng không ạ
mình sẽ được tia lưu lạc đường dẫn của
file này không ạ ở đoạn đấy à thính ở
Tôi làm rồi Vậy à à à
bây giờ trưa buổi ngày môn này chưa dậy
Cái đấy thì phải ok chị sẽ cần lưu lại
toàn bộ những cái này đẩy lên này cái
đấy làm vai bếp đúng không từ 3 đến này
cậu cứ làm ba đến đoạn này cẩn thận nha
à
à iMac web này
a Company này
sau đó đi store web này này
đây có
A slow thì có Company for work directly
khi trở về bản chất tôi mình chơi với ma
à
xem đơn sắc đây này tên Company này
không ạ
lại các bạn ấy tí mình nên đặt tên Đây
là
em lên cho nó là
I name Nhi mới đúng
em nghe máy Đúng
à à
Việt Nam này
cho thuê nhà bắt buộc phải có rồi mới
quay và string và bắt buộc phải điền có
a
good này cho Facebook bắt buộc phải điện
không được để trống
em có bị đơ này
ram cũng không phải lỗi mình
à à
em bắt máy Sao
Ừ cái này tôi đã nghĩa là thằng à
A Happy stone của tôi bị đơ rồi
à à
ở chỗ thằng tắt nay nó chạy ngầm nặng
quá
Chị xem thử nha
baby store màu chiếm khá nhiều do thằng
cái tóc nay chạy nặng cực
phải tắt FPT xô mới xong rồi trả thôi
thường mày tôi sẽ trong nhà cơ
Ừ chắc ở đây có khi tôi tắt sư cái tát
này không cần Tóc Na lắm nữa
ừ nhiều lúc nó gợi ý hay đấy nhưng mà ở
Ừ nó làm nặng treo nhà nhiều lúc khó
chịu cho nó khó chịu
bởi vì nó chia sẻ livestream này nó nặng
nữa cái like cốt cái code minh a nặng
Cha tôi tạm tắt đi được
Ừ để tôi xem có đi tắt được thì tắt nốt
đi
ờ ờ
à à
Ê phải mở đúng lại nhiều đấy
ở tập này
Anh tắt máy tôi không nhớ là tôi chúc
bạn miễn phí không mất tiền à
Ừ nếu anh mất tiền thì ta cũng không
phải do tôi lại mất tiền mà do
Vợ bận à
à mà do ông anh tôi chia sẻ kia
Ê phải làm gì đây
về sẽ lại cái này xem đồ đỡ đồ
đi xe đạp
cặp chạy như thế chết
file is not possible
Anh Hello gà OK OK
thì à
it is
A Gọi xuất treo luôn
in store audio
cậu anh đếch các thứ thôi đã anh hơi bị
treo vậy
mình đây sẽ còn em nhé
à à
tôi không gợi ý cả
anh gọi không gợi ý khó chịu thế không
có ai trên này
đây lần này
Nhưng mà lúc mà gợi ý ra nó cũng được
nhưng mà thôi bài toán anh đâu mình sẽ
có mi này đây
ờ ờ
220 tự như không gợi ý cảm thấy trống
vắng
City trình này
khi nuôi bồ cho lên đầu đi những cái bắt
buộc cứ cho nó lên đầu nha
Vì thế hiện ở bắt buộc phải điên này cái
gì đói à
với nó cũng không không đúng mình vẫn là
tự gõ mà như ra nó gợi ý ở đây nó có ý
nghĩa là có thể mình không dùng đúng
Mình không dùng nhưng mình vẫn kiểu oa
Ừ mình vẫn hiểu tham khảo Cái nó gợi ý
gì không Ví dụ mình quên chị lỗi
chính tả là nhãn nó sẽ lấy xuất ra chẳng
hạn đại khái thế vấn đề xuất hàn hộ mình
nha nó đọc hộ để xuất hành bộ mình anh
nhá Ờ
khác gì cái nút pass bệnh viện nói đừng
này
phải hỗ trợ gợi ý cái thứ thì nóng lạnh
chứ ngon đi công tác tôi lửa
trò chơi nhanh Express
a
b tôi gõ bình thường nó sẽ gỗ gõ viết hộ
tôi chữ Atlat đấy à
ở nhà tội
Anh nói đùa thôi được kìa bình thường là
thằng nhà thằng paste ôm nó có gợi ý sẵn
nó có nó có hỗ trợ gợi ý anh á Nhưng mà
tôi tắt sự gợi ý của nó đi để mà tôi
dùng cái Tab like đấy
Bây giờ tôi tất cả 8 like tất cả gợi ý
thằng pistone được
nói chắc là B chỉnh mạnh nhưng có việc
tìm kiếm thông báo lỗi có vấn đề gì đó
thì nó không gợi ý thêm cái gì cả thôi
cũng đủ Ừ mai mình gõ ngay
Số Phone này cứ để mặc định sau sinh
người dùng nhập sai có thể thứ kệ không
tật lần như thế Nhưng cái không có trọng
mà Ừ quan trọng cái cuối này nó logo vô
bản chất là mình sẽ cho truyền và là
file nghe chị ạ vẫn để trống
Ừ mình thể bắt buộc đúng định dạng của
nó là inmate cũng nhớ là có vụ đấy có
cái vụ vali tơ mình cho thêm inmates cảm
như thế như thế này ai thế còn nó sẽ
kiểm tra hộ mình này
anh kiểm tra hộ mình bắt buộc phải nằm
trong những cái đơn dẫn như thế này nó
tiện hơn bếp này và ông có thể cho giới
hạn dung lượng được Ừ thế giới hạn rất
là hai cái sai của nó ông
khi tôi thấy một trận kể hay nhất của nó
là cái này cái sai này nghĩa là ông khai
báo kiểu dữ liệu kiểu dữ liệu gì trên
hay là 5 Break Hải Vân Thuận chứa file
ngay sông kết hợp thì cái sai và cho nó
thì thì đây nó ví dụ là cái nó sai không
thì sẽ hiểu là độ dài 12 đến Tô Châu thì
sẽ hiểu sai đây sẽ ra cậu không được
phép lớn hơn mưa ấy đấy còn Android thì
sai đây lại hiểu không lực lớn 5 phần tử
đấy
à À không không phải lớn hơn à exact Hà
chính xác
chứ không phải thông minh lắm nhỉ Nhưng
mi mắt của thằng này thôi nhớ là có nhìn
mắt của thằng này nó sẽ là theo cái cũng
ở đây nó theo quy tắc như thế theo quy
tắc phải thằng say thì tôi thế nghĩa là
ông biết ông triển khai báo kiểu xong sẽ
phải bảo mi mắt nó sẽ đúng tuân theo quy
tắc của thằng này là sử bây giờ nha tôi
để nó là mắc nhà chẳng hạn là 500.000
ngại sẽ hiểu là là nó sẽ không được phép
lớn hơn 500 kg Probi Thực ra là 500k bye
sao lại thế nhỉ Em xem lại cái ảnh của
mình
hình ảnh của mình à
ở đây là 200K 3
anh Tâm à ảnh để cho tuần 50 rồi nhỉ là
sự thế
U50 50 năm nhìn đi không Các loại 5000
Vì sao mà chọn ảnh thứ hai ảnh logo mà
ảnh lớn hơn 5
phút nó để không trẻ
không không cần những cái ảnh được như
thế này Logo nó thấp lắm thì ra thoát
lắm Nó là s FPT Shop
ra sau đó mình sẽ lưu lại thôi mình sẽ
ở đây mình
bị quét đây này a story with the story
which đ
xe tải mèo thấy nó vẫn có gợi ý không ai
bảo để lắm ngon em đấy gợi ý cái tương
đối thôi Bây giờ sửa tôi gõ lên ngay đáy
bình thường bằng nhà nó sẽ thằng tắt nay
mới gợi ý tôi quét nên các thứ thứ
vì cuộc sống
ờ ờ
ở đây khi mình đẩy lên ý mình có hoàn
toàn thể Phi Apple nghĩa là mình có thể
lắp điện toàn bộ tất cả chỗ này những
cái xanh khác mình sẽ bỏ qua đông ạ thì
mình sẽ chỉ có mỗi cái logo này mình cần
phải thì đè nó lên mình sẽ lấy thế logo
này file logo nha Chẳng hạn Mình sẽ lưu
lại cái đường dẫn này thì thằng level
này thứ có cái vụ upload file hộ mình
rồi
ở Atlat này
mình sẽ lưu new Stories thẳng nhà luôn
Mà mình lấy là đường dẫn ra sao nên gọn
nhẹ ngoại
lần trước mình lưu file ảnh ở đâu nhỉ
Mình chưa làm vụ lưu file ở trong cái đồ
này đúng không Ok Bây giờ mình làm cách
lưu mình sẽ mình trước khi lưu Mình sẽ ở
luôn chạy cái đoạn này cái này là nó sẽ
tạo cái đường dẫn nối từ cái thông mục
auris của mình cái app public mình sẽ
nối thông qua cái cái đỉnh cái topic này
Để tí mình cho đường dẫn là chuẩn
hình ảnh
bây giờ mình sẽ đặt tên cho cái này cái
cái đây là không phân I đúng không
company
kinh
tế thực tế đó là
tùy tình huống hả Mấy ông sẽ lưu lại cái
này được loại như thế nào để về sau là
sử ông xóa theo người dùng sẽ xóa được
tôi đang lưu lại theo cập thư mục nhưng
ai cũng được không sao không sao nhưng
về sau mấy ông có thể cân nhắc việc và
là sửa ông lưu lại theo ID người dùng và
khi ông xóa người dùng xóa theo thư mục
có chứa ID người dùng toàn bộ nó sẽ bay
hả hay
cho ví dụ giả sử ở đây này chẳng án ông
hoàn toàn lưu lãi được ra sự nhá gọi đến
hàng đang đăng nhập là
gọi từ nay đi thì nói là sửa ngày Đúng
không ông sẽ không sẽ có một chung mục
như ai ra đấy ông ạ tôi về cho ông xóa
người dùng sẽ xóa toàn bộ những cái tham
xóa cả posts hay đi xóa cả tôi đi đi thì
ai hết ngoài cơ thể
a logo ngoại ô
ở Pháp như này của Pháp ở đây thôi à
tôi làm gì ý nhỉ
Ờ Ờ mình sẽ
khi Daisy crash
em sẽ gọi di quét logo ngay
tôi đè lên nó sau đó mình sẽ company
Ừ
chị sẽ chết
và sẽ truyền cái vì Quét họ đến vài đích
thực
à à
A và toàn bộ những thằng đã được vài vết
Hải
Có ai bán Xem
Ở đây toàn bộ hoài đã xem được nha à
Ừ ừ tao mày là tôi còn chưa có tóc em cơ
Chắc chắn là nó sẽ bị lỗi rồi đúng không
ạ
anh vẫn hôm qua đi rồi nghỉ
for này phải cần Token ấy nhỉ
em có mấy nhỉ Sao không chuyển lên nhỉ
Men filled with a nhô lên đây đang chưa
độ lại
em sợ thật ra đây nè Thế trưa nay
thế này này
nó
bảo OK logo không bị ghi đè lên với cách
ghi cách ghi còn này là chị lấy ra thôi
chứ nó không ghi đè lên à
ở đây bản chất ở mạng này Android I
rồi Tại logo này
chị
tôi sẽ D
ra được nó chạy thử lại
Ừ nó ok rồi này ngon rồi đó mình chỉ cần
truyền hướng dẫn đây này vào xong sẽ cho
đùa vậy Khuya bồ có đầy đủ tất cả không
ai thôi gì này
xin lỗi
- phu Blue canxi quản trị có trước đây
mà nhỉ đúng
I
can't mình nó không chuyển lên ngủ ngon
vừa nãy mình chiếu nghỉ canxi canxi mặc
định mình Việt Nam nhỉ Mình cứ để mặc
định Việt nam-nga kệ nhé à
nhập Campuchia
Việt Nam hết đi sang đất nước khác à
ở sang đất nước khác nhìn chó chọn Ừ ừ
như thế sẽ back often Dạo này em dậy đi
mình sẽ là
cách tạo einnahme Việt Nam Selection
mình sẽ là IMAX
a company
I can see I
Âm Nhạc
à
thằng tắt này bình thường là sẽ gợi ý
với Tôn cái đoạn này ạ
ừ ừ
ba tơ bay mình nên lưu lại là Mã
mạng cái dụng ngay
anh gặp em mã tâm chi code í
nữ ca sĩ Ra Xứ Huế
có gì không nhỉ Hôm trước tiền tệ Mình
là gì nhỉ
Mình cứ đúng theo công sinh nhá
I wish
a good night tết đấy thằng tát nay nó sẽ
gợi ý cho tôi rồi không phải biết đầy đủ
cái này cho nó alo alo thì ạ
cho anh à
Ừ ok
à à
ở châu Âu Trung á Ăn chuối yêu muốn Châu
chúng anh không thấy các đoạn này thì ra
tôi bảo đoạn này hơi sai vì tự nhiên
mình lưu lại căn suy ra xong rồi city
không có city của những cái đấy city ở
trọ ở Hà Nội để còn biết ở Hà Nội có
nghe vị sai không hiểu không
cho mặc định này
ở gần mình đưa canxi đang hơi Thu ạ sử
chỉ cho Việt Nam với cả
phải nhập City ở đi ship cho người dùng
nhập thủ công người dùng đoạn này mình
sẽ cho người dùng nhập thủ công vào
trong này nghĩa là một đợt theo cái mình
đang đề xuất hay cho người dùng nhập thủ
công mà Thì mình mới cho chọn chui nữa
đúng không
ngay
ờ ờ
Ăn
gì
để có canxi I
thông tin thẻ phẩm bắt buộc phải điền
đấy nhá
ờ ờ ờ
nhưng mà nhưng mà sợ Peter về sau của
vấn đề
thế
này thế kia à
Ừ địt à
Đó là một danh sách này à
Âm Nhạc
a City password phải điên này
phải điên à à
[âm nhạc]
ở đây
xe open
vì thế đây tôi sẽ có một cái là
A4
34 34 đây mình sẽ có Sunny có chân ở
trong trường hợp 2
khi mở canxi
Ồ thế hả đây mình sẽ phải
em mặc định mình phải loát là cái canxi
cho đây đã thì ở đây Tôi có một cái tôi
chỉ luôn cho Mấy ông hôm nay một cái mới
luôn thì mình cảm thấy là nó khác xịn
Nếu giả sử mặc định mà mình không cần
yêu mình chẳng bao giờ sửa thêm cái mới
trả cơ sở thêm cái mới thì mình sẽ có
thể cách Mình lưu lại cái giá trị mình
Mình lưu lại giá trị để mình lấy lấy ra
nó nhanh em yêu sao
rồi à
ta đã có bên post-war admin potsdamer
hôm trước thì tôi làm thì mới Ông thấy
là mình lưu lại kohl suy ra như này mình
lấy quần xi thẳng tới năm ra ngay mà rõ
ràng cô đơn xin của tôi gần như là sẽ
không giả sử gần như là về sau rất ít
khi thay đổi mà cứ mỗi mỗi lần tại lại
cha mình lại phải lấy cái danh sách này
ra ông ạ cái danh sách này không xa
nhưng mà nhiều lúc ở Mình lưu lại mình
lấy ra từ không không phải tử cái cánh
sen này nữa mà mình lấy ra từ đã ta bây
được ạ thì mình sẽ có khái niệm và cách
mình sẽ lấy từ trong cách ra những cái
gọi là Season Season Compaq
là cái cái giá trị mặc định của shop xin
nữa kiểu hệ của hệ thống ấy Mình sẽ lưu
lại toàn bộ Cái này và phong cách của
mình lấy được ít ra đứng nhiều Tôi đang
nói được là lấy lại lấy ra từ cốt như
này cái loại này nhắn không có gì cả lại
ở rất là nhanh thôi cách tất cả từ cái
kia nó nó chẳng thay Ừ mấy nhưng mà tôi
đang nói là có những cái lấy từ trong
bài ra sao rất nhiều cái về sau là sự
Mình lưu lại trong cái một bảng là không
thích em ạ thì việc là mình trỏ đến Lỡ
bài Lấy cái thứ mà nó luôn luôn cần nghĩ
thay đổi để lấy về thì mình sẽ lưu lại
tạm thời nó nó khái niệm về cách đưa tôi
sẽ thử Ví dụ như ở đây cho mấy ông một
cái ví dụ tôi sẽ tạo một cái
công ty tôi làm một điểm thì tổn thương
làm thế tôi sẽ lưu lại một cái cách này
sẽ thích Kỳ biểu tôi sẽ tạm một cái là à
assistant One Piece nghĩa là cấu hình
của xứ Sơn này ăn cho này
này tôi sẽ tạo một cái xưởng có fix này
Sau đây tôi sẽ có khái niệm là gì đó thì
tôi sẽ
này
à à
chị sẽ lấy tôi sẽ lấy cho chị ra và cách
đó lại và tôi sẽ gọi Ca na sát tích sự
tích để mà tí Tôi đỡ phải ngu Thằng này
mà tôi sẽ gọi được cậu 2.ai chấm Được
đấy Bà đây tôi sẽ ghi tên về
ở đây là Quân Shi các từ đúng không Đúng
không
hai mẹ con ic này
cái nữa là canxi đúng không
ngày gì
à à
cần chi ngay Hãy giả sử như này không ạ
Tôi sẽ sửa lại đây Nó là một cái mặt tôi
lưu nói lại trong dạng mạnh nha à
Ừ nó giấc more ở đây này nếu lại toàn bộ
này trong một cái mặt sau đó thì tôi sẽ
Return hẳn về thằng này nha à
đây cái ha mày bản chất là tôi sẽ với
mạng nha Và cứ mỗi lần
em mỗi lần cần ra cái gì Tôi sẽ gọi đến
cái thằng season cân fecal này là tôi sẽ
gọi cái hàm
cái topic này à
ở trong này và hoàn toàn là ông có thể
ví dụ giả sử như trường hợp này ông gọi
cu C đúng không Con fix Quân sĩ này à
ở
các sự thế Ra Xứ Huế Thì dụng tiếp theo
là cần chuyển mã cũng sẽ gọi đấy cắm Duy
như này
này Nhưng mà cái này mới chỉ đang tiện
là có chung hết mà trong cái hàm để mà
ông ấy dễ gọi như thế này Thế bây giờ
giả sử là tôi vừa nói về khái niệm cách
để lưu lại thì tức là sao Thế làm chỉ à
Tôi đỡ phải lấy ra từ đoạn này thậm chí
lấy từ tao bay cái gì đó là sự trong.ai
bên mình lưu cái gì nhỉ xưởng mình chưa
language ạ tôi muốn lấy toàn bộ lanh
quyn ra chẳng hạn để người dùng chọn
đúng loại thi
Ừ cái bạn này Hôm trước mang web cho
mình hiển thị ra ở đâu nhỉ các bạn đã
biết mình lấy ra là
Ừ Đấy mình lại phải có acid lên để lấy
toàn bộ lông ích về đúng không Không thể
không đấy thì mình sẽ cách nó lại chẳng
hạn thì đây tôi sẽ khách lại luôn toàn
bộ nó biết về nhá Ừ
dùng điện thêm này không không không Thế
chắc chắn là cách chạy rồi thì ở đây
mình sẽ có language này hay vì mình cậu
có mỗi lần mình lại gọi truy phần ABBank
thế này là không Chúng ta sẽ không làm
thế mà chúng ta đây mình sẽ mình sẽ có
đây thêm cái logo
à à
sao ạ
sau đó thì
ạ bây giờ thay vì gọi ngay để đỡ thì tôi
chỉ rõ nhé
Anh bình thường là không có lần tôi gõ
như này thì nó lại tìm kiếm và đẩy lên
và mặc định nó sẽ tìm kiếm celexa phẩm
như thế này đúng không ạ đúng không Đúng
thấy không thì thay vì như thế sẽ cách
trở lại mình sẽ ở đây có khái niệm mà
with ơn
3 cách lại
anh xóa báo thì remember
thế này mình sẽ có lưu lại đề con fix
này chẳng
Anh tên tên của chi đây sau đó ông sẽ
lưu lại trong vòng bao lâu thực tế hội
trước tôi bị lạm dụng là tôi dùng vi
number forever nghĩa lưu lại vĩnh viễn
sau đó thì sếp cần đây có bảo tôi là
không nên làm thế bởi vì về sau nếu
trong trường hợp mà mình quên không xóa
cái key này đi không xóa kết cái đi nó
sẽ bị ra là nặng lưu lại trên máy thế là
về sau béo không bao giờ không không ngờ
Nên cậu
rapper five-o nên đặt một cái thời gian
gì đó để mà mình còn giải phóng bộ nhớ
hay gì đó Tiện về sau biết đâu cập nhật
gì đó nó cập nhật nè thường là lưu ở này
vợ căng nhất thì ông chỉ nên lưu tối đa
là một tháng thôi tôi Giả sử tôi có lưu
một ngày đi sẽ 24 giờ nhân 60 phút
nhân 60 giây nhìn này con chuyện này
à à
ừ ừ
Em hãy cho tôi sẽ Return toàn bộ thằng
Ngày Về
Ê nói nghe này cái đoạn này tức là sao
Mình sẽ lưu lại toàn bộ vào trong cái
cách mà lưu lại hộ mình đỡ phải truy vấn
một cái gì nữa tôi thử đối nhiều tôi gọi
lại cái ipa này nó sẽ bị có vấn đề Em có
sẽ sửa lại Tôi sẽ gọi đến hãm như thế
này
ta season II
thế này sẽ con fix này
đến Hàng nhà anh em mình chỉ quan tâm
thông with đúng ạ ta này bằng
con làm có ích này
à à
ở Hưng Yên là ông sẽ thấy ra nhiều không
sẽ thấy là nó sẽ không có tìm kiếm hộ
cho mấy ông đã để thử nha
xe tải người không phải không hề có một
câu truy vấn nào nữa và bản chất là mình
sẽ lấy từ đâu mình sẽ lấy từ trong cách
của mình ra
tôi nhớ nó trong mày có cách gì vậy ở
Sơn La kho quẹt
Ừ
ở đại thả thế mày ông không hề thấy một
câu truy vấn nào nữa không ạ ấy thì tiếp
theo là để đương nhiên là mấy ông thấy
giống tôi vừa nói nó Cậu cũng hộ Tìm
kiếm không ạ thì mới ông sẽ chỉ cần tìm
kiếm trong trình cái mảnh này thôi Thằng
này Bây giờ nó là Collection ông sẽ dùng
clip xe này ông tìm kiếm sẽ filter Theo
nó là được ông sẽ dùng hành Peter này nó
có cái ở Vera bồ này ông dùng hàm Peter
để ông tìm kiếm và Sao lại như này thế
là xong
trò
chuyện này Vào trong này ông sẽ có đây
là ông Peter theo còn gì nhà ông khi tôi
theo nêm rồi đúng không sẽ truyền nêm
vào xong rồi like Thực ra B không like
được ông sẽ So sánh chỗ dùng hàm tìm
kiếm trong chuỗi của TP là được
vì ai bây giờ sự thằng Tuần hàng ngày
tuần hành này đúng không Mình sẽ có từng
hàng tại vị trí nêm
mình mình cần trả về những cái thằng nào
thỏa mãn cái thằng ạ Mình sẽ truyền đây
là yêu Harry quét ở đây mình sẽ cần
bộ phim sex cần lấy Nhận Hà thỏa mãn cái
khi cây quý này quy truyền lên mạng sẽ
là
ông sẽ có khái niệm dùng thêm một cái
nữa của thằng hepl có sẵn bằng rally cho
xịn là
nó bảo bây giờ bạn chắc chắn là chỗ ấy
mà mình tìm kiếm trong chuỗi này có chứa
cái tên được không thì mình sẽ dùng là
cái khái niệm của công tên là kiểm tra
trong chuỗi sự
xe container
à à
Có ai nghe này là xong
hình ảnh này kiểm tra xem nó có Tùng cái
Trỗi nêm này có tồn tại cái thằng cu
không có chị sẽ trả hết về tôi sẽ tìm
kiếm lại mấy ông nhá á
ăn gì đây có bị ngập điểm Cái đó mấy ông
thấy ra đối với thằng đối với Tìm kiếm
của thằng Wow thì khi mà dùng like thì
nó sẽ không phân biệt có dấu và vẫn
không phục không phân biệt hoa thưởng
trong trường hợp này có dấu được không
sao bởi vì bản chất là ngôn ngữ lập
trình mình làm cái có dấu đâu không ạ
nhưng mà mình cần phải khó phân biệt hoa
thưởng nên là ông có thể chơi trò là
string to wear đây nữa Ép kiểu nó thành
ạ dạ mà khi mà tìm kiếm thì mình tìm
kiếm bỏ qua việc và viết hoa này
bậy nữa nó ngọt ngào cũng vậy thôi không
ừ ừ
ý thì cái cách này mình sẽ lưu lại điều
đấy Tôi vừa hôm nay của chị thêm mấy ông
thêm cả cái mới nữa không ạ Ấy
làm để hộ posts in xơ và cơ mình vẫn
đang thấy quay quần tí Đợi tí Đợi tí giờ
còn căn chui này mình cần đổ nó ra đúng
không ạ Mình cần đổ cần chi ra mình sẽ
đây mình sẽ căn chi chuyen can xi trong
ai Nói lời sẽ là
Em hỏi nó cắn truyền
chuyện
đáng lẽ nó phải có gợi ý rồi nhưng mà
không kìa
em
học sinh ở
anh ở đây ở đây thì canxi mình chuyển ra
À thì ra là nó sẽ ở đây là nên này vào
đây mới value này
à à
thì mình sẽ in ra cái nêm
đúng nhỉ
ở lợn cắm truyền hình cái nha à
value sự mình cần lưu lại nhoi có bao
lâu rồi đây
A
Gọi Blue
điền cái gì đó Mình đăng ký không đi
uống cà phê gì không tồn tại cho mình
ingress Nó sẽ hiển thị ra cái Ok Để mình
chọn đây mặc định là mình không cho chọn
ngoài danh sách này nhưng cái City lại
đi cheat ngày ra sự mình vẫn muốn cho
chọn sách này thì sao tại sao đây thằng
đi chết nó không tự động
em không tự động lót nhà Con Tội Lỗi gì
đấy
lỗi gì đó lỗi
lỗi gì đó
Ừ cái lỗi Token này liên hoan việc à
chị đã nó
à à
A6 snack
a Talent gọi her parents
a slack location
em có vấn đề gì không nhỉ parent
a-class này vẫn vẫn là class đấy nhỉ để
xem nhé homegroup
Anh
gọi sao ngày à
phim ít của thằng level nó hỗ trợ sự
giới hạn các hình thức
à
hay là tránh cũng tránh một phần nào đó
về việc ở truy cập liên tục vào
chị Thu Thủy nó truy truy cập liên tục
vàng thì nó bị quá tải nhưng mà ở nó bảo
mật phá ông chỉ có như cách mà
khi
chờ một cái Để mà giải quyết được à mình
không chắc quá nhiều cũng nha tốc độ
loáng anh ờ
em nghe nó kêu lát YouTube nhờ không
được lỗi gì đó
ừ ừ
anh lại lại có khí ở liên quan đến đường
dẫn nào đó rồi à
rồi Nếu mà không Nếu mà không tìm được
đường dẫn mà em mình phải bỏ qua đây mới
đúng
không nhập City mà
em đừng dẫn không không được không Nếu
mà ít
em không có đường dẫn này thì mình sẽ
Return thẳng về luôn Bỏ qua ngay ạ Thế
không không bị nhảy xuống đây có lỗi nữa
được mà Talent Talent Talent
ở đây mình có operon ở đây rõ ràng có
bao lần mà nghỉ à
an ninh
parent
a parent à
được đèn ha
ở đây lại
à Rồi rồi rồi Tôi hiểu rồi bọn ta luôn ở
đây nó Ừ nó bị nhầm sang thằng thằng cắn
chui này chứ phải tháng City Ok Ok nó sẽ
gọi đến hàng à City
thì tại sao dạo này sai nghĩa là đoạn
này mình sẽ phải gọi đến City
ai cho mày đến tiếp thì mình mới gọi đến
á
Anh quên rồi đấy
à Xong rồi à
chị sẽ select City Đà Nẵng
sau đó thì gọi đến hàng ốp chân này à
có gj mới làm đoạn mình đã làm nhà ngay
thôi
khi tôi bắt đầu yêu view hơn à
anh không được nhà phát hành này vẫn vấn
đề chọn cho đến kiểu này tôi Nghĩa không
cho được
anh mạnh quá thế
trường hợp Nếu giả sử tôi bảo rồi bây
giờ mình sẽ hỗ trợ cho cả việc là select
City ở đây mình vẫn thể cho Điền City
nào đó mà không Không Thuộc nữa thì như
thế nào sẽ phức tạp hơn không ạ rồi cảm
ơn khá nhiều đây City ở đây trong hộp
này mình sẽ cho
dù cho có tác có thể cho điền thêm vào
sẽ sao chuẩn hết chúng mày á á
à bác luôn nhỉ
công tác
cho tác cả chua này không phải chuyển
lên cái ta cả Chu như này nữa
ở
đây tác Cà Chua tác cả Chu cho mấy cái
xếp hay này
a tatsu Yasuo à
à à
sử chọn là
canxi khác thì sẽ ra cái gì đó
I bought mình thì tao không cần lắm
nhưng cho chọn City
lại vẫn được
anh ấn vào
à Quên à
A và
ở đó Thực ra cái này mình sẽ tự động
Điền nữa Nhưng có vẻ Đang cho mắt được
đẩy lên ôi tôi bắt đầu thấy làm đoạn này
kiểu cẩn thận quá kỹ tính quá nó bị lâu
thật
ở đâu đấy mà lâu rồi toàn lâu ra Swift
chưa
à nho đây có thể điện được thành phố
khác này an tỉnh khác rồi này ok
Ừ
dạo này thôi rườm rà quá bỏ quá người
dùng bắt buộc phải dùng điện lại cái này
cho vui được
ở Việt Nam này chọn được quốc gia khác
này chọn cái này để nhảy sang cái khác
này thể bấm thử bấm thử nhé Ấn vào này
lưu lại store này được lại tất cả đồng
Này đẩy lên
khi họ chuyển lên có mẹ có vẻ thành công
ấy
Mẹ Maria minh nha đẩy lên bạn này cũng
dễ mà Dạo này mình quét hàng luôn mà
không báo lỗi tức là thành công rồi sẽ
Return ở đây Sắp xít này được chính xác
xít ở đây là được
hợp mà nếu mà tí xuất được thì nó mới
sắp xít thường là tôi thường ai cho chai
cát ở đây nếu có vấn đề gì đó mình sẽ
internet lô đấy
Âm Nhạc
Ê mày đâu nhỉ
khi sex
ừ ừ
nếu có vấn đề đó sẽ biến anh alo bạn nó
sẽ thông báo thế thời sự tạo cái nữa nó
sẽ alo này nếu không mấy ông mấy ông
muốn in lỗi ra thì mới ông sẽ gọi đến
kiểu nếu không sẽ truyền thêm phí ship ở
trong này để ý cụ thể nó lỗi gì ngay đấy
ở nhà Thực tế à mày Ông thấy mà in lỗi
như này cho người dùng không nên người
dùng những người dùng chẳng hiểu được
cái đoạn này nó gì đúng ạ thì nó sẽ có
thêm cái khác là ông đầu tiên ông sẽ lắp
cũng sẽ ông sẽ bắt cái đấy
ai
cho mày không xem nha
thứ hai tôi dậy qua với cả trái cam luôn
này ông sẽ thấy à Nó nó sẽ bản chất là
thằng này nó đều có một cái mã khi cốt
cái cốt nào đó để lỗi gì đó xảy ra đây
tôi sẽ
có phải thêm
ghép cốt ở đây cho mày không Xe này là
in a lỗi như này
ra cái lỗi mã lỗi là kẹo 22300 không
nghe chẳng lại đây trông sẽ hoàn toàn
không thể
Ừ ông sẽ biến Tải maxxis nó có ý nghĩa
hơn một tí trong người dùng
em chẳng hạn thế
thì nó sẽ là kiểu Nếu mà e kết Cốt
e Băng Băng Băng
23000 nha chẳng hạn
em biết cái này trả về nó số gì nữa
ạ
Bây giờ nó là chuỗi nó chuỗi như này
chẳng hạn thế
Thì mình sẽ đi Tôn trả về cho người dùng
là là kiểu thông báo một cái gì đó hẳn
hoi tử tế đi tôi thường hay đẩy nó một
cái Miss ít như này trên khung này
lúc đầu cho là trống số đó trong chụp
chụp này tôi sẽ làm ít dễ bằng dụng là
đắp liên kết
à à Company lên rồi nhắn lễ
hội clip trai ghê là cái gì đó tùy mày
không đặt ạ
hình ảnh như này số cuối ông sẽ trả về
cái mít như thế này là sao ạ
hình ảnh bảo tôi thử
chú chó message in là như này hoàn toàn
ông thích kiểm tra đây đều sắp xít là
phone thì ông sẽ in ra một cái notified
cái lỗi kèm theo cái mấy Sim kia chưa
sẽ lại tiếp tục phần năm sau nhờ hôm nay
ngoài việc dài như thế tôi chia sẻ chia
sẻ được thêm Mobile kiến thức tôi nghĩa
là cũng vẫn là mới cho mấy ông mình cái
kiểu các thứ thứ còn về chia sẻ về cái á
tiện ích này có thể tha thứ thì chắc là
lại phải nhường buổi sau nhé chứ buổi
hôm nay bị dài quá Tôi không muốn mấy
hôm nay toàn 2 tiếng thì nó hơi bị không
nhận hơi bị nặng ngoài được là tội giảm
bớt cho bớt nặng rồi
anh làm sao mỗi buổi một cái thức cho
các thực tế là mình xong cái xong mỗi
cái thêm này sau đó thì xanh ở bên bên
ứng cử viên ap cân đấy nói anh xong rồi
làm nốt về phần hiển thị là tìm kiếm là
có nhờ trang web này đã tương đối hoàn
chỉnh để trong mấy ông dùng được rồi sau
đó thì về sau bổ sung dần những tính
năng khác sau này
anh hả
Ừ ok nhỉ Đúng rồi bạn kia nói chuẩn đấy
Hôm nay thì ca hay nhất là cách này cách
này cũng nhận là kiểu nhiều hồi mà tôi
mới biết thì cũng Khai Sáng khá nhiều ạ
lực cái mấy ông xe buổi sáng Chào mấy
ông nha à